[Music]  okay anytime now  shut up  okay you got a plan or should i just  stay dug and go my plan was to drive us  away  well your plan sucks  you're welcome you don't know everything  about me  i've lived a lot of lives  [Music]  before i was an avenger  before i got this family  i made mistakes choosing between what  the world wants you to be  and know you are  [Music]  we have to go back to where it all  started  where did you think i was all this time  we have unfinished business  my girls are the toughest girls in the  world i'm sorry  we had our orders and we played our role  it wasn't real  it was real to me  to me you were everything  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  one thing's for sure  [Music]  i'm done running for my past  [Music]  you